philosophy is in trouble no one studies
it anymore kids don't give a damn about
it that's why we went to visit a very
special man and gave him a very big
challenge this philosophical Jam fizzle
we jammed 8:1 um Jim I've got a really
Jamie I've got a really cheeky thing to
ask you okay um what you know about
philosophy I don't know not interested
in it yeah no I think I'm really
philosophical I think you are but I was
quite uneducated at school if I'm really
honest yeah and we would never taught it
and and possibly what I think philosophy
is it isn't so okay look you can help me
I'd love to help you but look here's a
challenge the thing about philosophy is
it's dying on its feet
no one's studying at university subjects
dying actually it contains so much
goodness so many lessons that we need to
know hopefully your life's going to be
another 40 years 50 years hope something
like that hopefully my life a bit longer
- I wouldn't say that I long but I would
like that at some point in your life you
do - philosophy what you've done with
food in other words that you take people
who see this thing that's so scary and
you unpack it for them and you prepare
it for them and you teach them that it's
something that they could engage it if
you made a program on philosophy
anywhere social media airwaves etc it
would literally change culture you would
change the history of culture because
this is a subject that is full of
richness and goodness but it's like a
like an artichoke cooking an artichoke
and there's a lovely heart in it but it
needs unpicking so you are the man to do
it when I'm talking to my like 12 year
old and leading roles
yeah about what are the principles the
basic principles of philosophy but
basically it starts with the idea that
our brains are slightly misfiring faulty
walnuts there's things that are wrong
with our brains right our brain is a
faulty walnut I know that's a fact with
mine yes my brain is never with the task
of culture and philosophy in particular
is to give that faulty walnut things
that will
balanced steady and I'm calm honest all
the things that we want we can't do that
on our own and modern culture leaves us
so alone it basically just tells you you
know go to your you know school degree
etc and then off you go there used to be
religion that would sit you down once a
window or you know you'd be nice at
cetera that's gone away we're alone now
we're alone with the movies you know
with with the telly with you know what's
on the news etc that we're basically
alone and there's lots of entertainment
but there's not much wisdom in our
culture so in a funny sort of way it's a
sort of anemia that we have like we it's
something we're not going we've
forgotten the goodness that's there in
our culture it's it's what you're doing
with food right you've had to wrestle
with people's fear first of all I'm a
man I don't cook or I'm a working-class
English man I don't cook separate you've
battled a lot of prejudices and you've
got people in the kitchen big time when
it comes to culture things like
philosophy are held back by exactly the
same problem simple thing uh you know
I've not been educate I can't get
involved in all that thing and I that
drives me as mad as it drives you crazy
when people say I can't you know I don't
know what to do with an olive right you
go mad you've course you can and I'm
fascinated by that challenge but I don't
have what you have which is charm you
are dealing as I know people relate to
you right and so that's why it would be
lovely and I know you've done this a bit
with you know your school program etc if
you move more towards not just the
physical health which you've dealt with
so brilliantly but also mental emotional
well-being this is a huge topical and
you are literally the man on this planet
that's currently spinning around and
devoid you are the man who can best do
this and I would love you to get
interested in that challenge and I'd
love to give you the tools to take out
that challenge because I think you would
change how people think and you know we
live in a culture that's so divided
between high culture and low culture the
high guys don't talk to the low guys the
low guys they talk to the high guys
you're uniting them and you know
bringing into properly democratizing the
problem is that Jamie has existing
commitments his team are fully focused
on producing programs about food we have
to persuade Jamie and most of all his
people that he should do a series on
philosophy it could be a piece of
landmark TV
if you agree press the like button on
this video and pass it on to friends and
we'll petition the powers that be and
try to make it happen with your help
Jaime cooks philosophy starts now